[Music]
what does it mean to learn how to die in
order to learn how to live as photonic
it philosophy itself the meditation
preparation for death and fade up
Montaigne said philosophizes to learn
how to die Seneca says he or she who
learns how to die unlearn slavery
because art by day a deep education not
cheap schooling deep education is about
a critical self-examination of that
which is inside of us that needs to die
the fears the cowardice the complacency
the conformity the assumptions of the
presuppositions the prejudices of
prejudgment that we have that need to go
James Brown called it give it up turn it
loose it needs to go just like falling
in love you fall in love with somebody
something has died in you man Carson's
understand this well in her classic sums
died in you there you go ISM the fear
the narcissism I know a lot of people
don't understand to go full fledge death
but it's an effort because you're now in
tango with a new self and that new self
means you have been transformed and lo
and behold you walk around with smile on
your face feeling good before South
holds bittersweet hit you that's part of
love to in bittersweet out in hitches
just sentimental we're not gonna go into
that though but the connection of
learning how to die in a saddest feature
of our moment regard to divorce his
first question is that so many young
brothers and sisters of the younger
generation find themselves so far
removed from the best of their past far
removed from what has gone the best that
has gone into shaping and molding them
that all they have relation is market
forces market forces market forces
stimulation titillation
a hungry for care and nurture hungry for
something deeper that's what the
spiritual and moral awakening on young
people in the last five or ten years is
all about the hunger for what Astron
simpson called a real thing and what is
the dianna Zeke and what is the real
thing well it's something that is
dynamic you never get your hands on it
is intangible but it has everything to
do with the ways in which love the ways
in which justice in motion generate hope
generate encouragement generate a
certain sense of enthusiasm for what is
to come
anticipation of the not yet rooted in
the ugly what is an erisa block and
others talked about in the classic on
philosophy of hope the volume on
philosophy of Hope that's what the boys
has in mind with integrity our young
people these days more and more I spend
a lot of time with in fact I've shifted
most of my lectures now to both prisons
and high schools and junior High's so
hungry for something that pierces
through the spectacle and the image they
want something that they can hold on to
essa stench Allah that's why the music
is a fundamental battlefield that's one
of the crucial sites of the spiritual
warfare
there's no accidentally eliminated arts
programs in the 1980s under Reagan Trump
narrow their imagination attenuate their
and empathy let them just be bundles of
desires that these corporations can
manipulate in order to convince them to
be only consumer so that the profits can
go up we can push the workers against
the wall and therefore think that we are
actually sustaining a democratic
experiment rather than undermining its
soul and ending it with a similar than
of some simulacra of democracy because
you no longer have citizens you just
have consumers
okay have a democracy with just
consumers and what was the response oh
he'll come here pup just your old
brother I'm truth magnificent way she
laid it out 25 years ago you eliminate
the art program okay we're not gonna
produce anybody that sounds as good as
sarahvani donny hathaway anymore so i'm
lucky - singing - cuz they haven't been
taught well they don't have examples
because it's no longer in churches they
own church where they don't get it they
don't get it on the radio but lo and
behold they can make more money but not
necessarily imitating the best but they
did anyways connect the best that's why
they went to Sly Stone that's why they
went to Curtis made for the fly they
went to George Clinton why they went to
James Brown they went to a reefer they
sample that they couldn't play it any
more there's no instruments to learn how
to play but it had the sample and user
orality in the genius of their language
to keep the tradition alive and what
happened 15 years later you don't even
have any groups that seem together
anymore no dramatis no Delfonics no main
ingredient no whispers no bands like
James Brown a lakeside so computers and
individuals isolated monadic individuals
you see that's spiritual warfare you
dissin able the spiritual armor that's
kept of people going because usually
that's all black people have had our
voices in each other no land no
territory no rights no protection from
the state but at least we had our voices
that preserved our dignity a sense of
style and our empathy what happens when
that is more and more stripped away whoa
then you're gonna have a Hobbesian war
of all against all which is in part a
description of where our precious poor
and working-class youth of color and
poor youth
have to live every day and there's no
serious discussion about Democratic
Party Republican Party thank God for
Bernie Sanders but that's another
lecture to bring this to a close the
first question I'll show integrity
meeting person second question what is
honors to do in the face of deception
thank God for the best of the artists
what does it mean to be candid in age of
mendacity and criminality crime has been
normalized
no serious talk about drone strikes even
no crimes taking place all the time
how come it's normalize it's naturalized
we just come to accept it no that's
catastrophe you're killing innocent
people is wrong it's that's more than
wrong it's easy fall don't get used to
evil indifference the evils when videos
and evil itself says rabbi hatch is
right about that way and James's
indifference is the one trait that makes
the very Angels weep he's right about
that we've normalized criminality last
couple of days two more policemen off
right killing a young black folk it's
normal it's normal
anybody knows that County killer was
going on in Beverly Hills
Sookie's okay now should be major moral
outrage in every corner of the contract
we'll be killing these upper-class white
brothers this is like that they're human
being what about tomorrow on the future
what about Juanita Carlos what about our
indigenous brothers sisters reflect in
these reservations
oh you normalize that just keep moving
you deodorize it because you afraid of
the fault on your country you don't want
to deal with the phone well you can't
talk about hope without a spine to be a
fault master
that's what the funk is all about Samuel
Beckett called the domestic third
question what his decency do in the face
of insult an assault what is indecent
callousness and indifference for the
poor and vulnerable last question what
is courage during the fatal book in the
face of brute force force hope is about
being doing in acting embodying
connected to quest for integrity honesty
decency and courage plus magnanimity
namely fortitude
so in the end is not about how
sophisticated my discourse on hope was
it's about at your funeral she lived a
life in which she was a hope and she
generated hope in others as Curtis
Mayfield saying keep on push not a
discourse on pushing it's an enactment
in the mass in the font in catastrophe
in domination insubordination did not
allow any of them to have the last word
there is no hope without a wrestling of
despair it's like Jacob in the 32nd
chapter of Genesis where he's wrestling
with an angel of death in the midnight
hour and he emerges as God wrestler
that's the definition of Israel God
wrestling with new energy it's not this
course only I'm not against this course
but this course can become such a
distraction and we live in a culture
that specializes in weapons of mass
distraction as well as weapons of mass
destruction and it might be the case
that we lose now in America to talk
about losing as always a dangerous thing
because we live in a superficial culture
of winners you know we got to be with
the winner got to be with a women
no there is something about
acknowledging that you might lose that
gives a graphic toss to what you're
doing and then we may be surprised by
the joy of the process and sometimes
you'll be surprised by some of the
concrete victories
[Music]